on the package of all these major
reforms that Greece had committed to
last summer we have now a full agreement
a lot of legislative work already being
done by the Greek government and the
institution's will do a final check on
that to look at the last legislative
work and to see whether that's all in
agreement part of that of course is also
the contingency mechanism to make sure
that Greece stays on the fiscal path the
ESM will be able to endorse the
supplemental MOU and then approved the
disbursement of the second tranche of
this program the figure that we have
outlined for that is 10.3 a billion to
be dispersed in several disbursements
above all this opens the way for a
return of the confidence that is so
essential for a lasting economic
recovery in Greece which is a common
purpose so yes it is very important
moment that long and sometimes difficult
story we found the agreement for the
disbursement of the second tranche under
this current program second tranche will
amount to ten point three billion euro
this will follow the first tranche of 21
billion euro which was dispersed as you
remember during sep tember to december
of last year greece now needs to
implement all the outstanding prior
actions once this is done the ESM member
states will go through their national
procedures in order to give a mandate to
their port numbers to take the necessary
legal decisions in the ESM board of
directors we are willing to recommend a
management and staff asst will to
recommend to our board that this can
this is a staff level agreement that can
form there
for IAS support provided that before the
end of the year provided that the death
suit a revised that sustainability
analysis that we will be under to know
producing in in the coming months before
then we'll will suggest that that the
measures that are under on the table
will deliver the the necessary debt debt
relief